tranquille justement
union de chaque jeu compenser des
personnes positives au comique qui
peuvent aller voter alors finalement
c'est la noix est d'abord c'est un débat
un petit peu milles entre nous parce que
c'est obligatoire heureusement qu'ils
peuvent aller voter on vous vend même
comprenait la disney est bien sûr ils
doivent pouvoir aller voter il faut
respecter le vote de chaque citoyen mais
il faut permettre il faut permettre à ce
qui est des masques ffp2 à l'entrée de
chaque bureau de vote il faut permettre
et que ce soit pas aux communes de payer
d'ailleurs un mais on peut permettre à
ce que chaque citoyen puisse voter
trouvé ça complètement fou parce que
c'est là dessus c'est la démocratie qui
est en jeu derrière mais entre nous il
n'y a pas de débat entre candidats à
l'élection présidentielle il ya même un
candidat président de la république qui
voudrait être président sans débat qui
voudrait être même président sans être
candidat ça ça me choque par contre mais
que tout le monde puisse aller voter y
compris ceux qui malheureusement sont
testés positivement qu'on leur met un
masque ffp2 qui puisse aller voter
exprimer leur choix c'est tellement
important et on voit tous on va tous
pleuré parce qu'on va voir un taux
d'abstention énormément élevé le premier
le 10 avril au premier tour et puis on
dire ah bah oui mais alors on leur art
les a stigmatisé l'eau qui l'a pas voulu
débat avec ceinture allant mais alors il
ya des gens qui trouvent ça incohérent
totalement et de la cohérence je suis
d'accord moi oui je pense c'est que sa
seigneurie est trop bonne mercer que le
roi le roi de france est trop bon parce
qu'il accorde au français finalement
dans une déclaration solennelle nous
allons autoriser les personnes positif
locaux vides à aller voter peut-être
qu'on pourrait essayer de lui rappeler
qu'il ya un truc qui s'appelle le droit
constitutionnel tout à fait est que sur
ce point il n'a pas le choix donc ils
arrêtent de s'attribuer des mérites qui
sont ceux de la loi et de la
constitution
ça c'est le premier pure est sûr qu'il
soit attribué le mérite et je suis pas
sûr qu'il fait une déclaration
officielle c'est pas en paroles gabriel
attaque qui va annoncer aujourd'hui le
bâtiment et ont pas l'annoncer il n'a
pas dit on autorise sait jamais mais mon
ton c'est pas grave il y effectivement
le retour parole du gouvernement n'est
pas d'une déclaration officielle ça on
est bien d'accord et c'est ce que
devient parole du gouvernement a
récemment mis d'accord d'accord
deuxième élément donc on est d'accord on
est parfaitement d'accord sur le fait
qu'il faut que les positif au covic
allez voter dans les conditions ainsi
prévu et je suis d'accord avec monsieur
roussel sur le fait qu' il importe que
les masques prévu le cas échéant mais à
condition que soient pas les communes
qui les paie sage mais deux c'est pas
une donc on est d'accord c'est à dire
que maintenant on va arrêter d'emmerder
un vocabulaire présidentielle les
non-vaccinés négatif que concrètement le
pass sanitaires à l'hôpital on est
d'accord que c'est fini on n'en parle
plus parce qu'aujourd'hui comme des
français qui peuvent pas accéder à
l'hôpital sauf s'ils payent 25 balles
pour y aller mais c'est maintenant le
rapport il est celui que je fais mathieu
a aussi évoqué la parole je vais essayer
de faire les propres rapports d'accord
non merci j'ai un deuxième élément
d'ailleurs j'attends toujours ton appel
pour déjeuner non c'est autre chose ça
fait un gros
service et moi qui paye
là c'est sûr tu vas voir tu peux même
nom deuxième point c'est que on est sur
une incohérence qui est profonde en fait
à un moment donné le vrai souci
aujourd'hui c'est que on dit que le coc
vide est derrière nous et c'est ce qui
est effectivement le positionnement
qu'il s'agit d'adopter aujourd'hui où on
dit qu'il faut alors prendre des mesures
parce que ces catastrophes etc mais il
faut qu'on arrête parce que maintenant
tout le monde sait qui est derrière ce
qu vide tout le monde sait qu
effectivement derrière ses machines sec
et derrière sur kobe tout le monde le
sait c'est pas derrière locaux vie
pardon et lisa on atteint prête pas mes
propos mais derrière les mesures anti
qu'ovide on sait que le pass and it rc
mckinsey 11 perf avec
je veux dire mais vous avez droit si
vous l'exigez droit de ne rien lire
c'est votre droit le plus élémentaire
mais effectivement contenus en ligne
rien de rapports de l'année par le
magazine s'est depuis une semaine tous
mineurs non courants se dire il pas
demandé au courant que ça mc kinsey qui
a géré la crise reid a consacré le koala
pour que baky mais c'est parce que je
suppose également on vous le savez pas
ce que j'ai dit ce que je dis c'est que
concrètement aujourd'hui on a un vrai
problème c'est qu'on s'aperçoit mais je
trouve ça bien que le gouvernement
annonce de la sorte les choses parce
qu'aujourd'hui on sait de manière
parfaite que la gestion de cette crise a
été une gestion politique et que quand
ça arrange et le gouvernement nous
n'avions aucune difficulté particulière
à stigmatiser les 1 an ferme et les
autres et lorsque effectivement ça
n'arrange pas le gouvernement est bien
celle inverse qui se produit mais
pourquoi sa norme nationale autant de
laurent la toile en gt c'est compliqué
parce que entrer dans le cerveau de
fabrice de vision c'est disons d'études
non mais voilà je pourrais nommer le
problème c'est que tout est tellement
déjà écrit dans sa tête que c'est
compliqué de rentrer la moindre
information on pourrait débarquer tout
ce qu'il dit toutes les 30 secondes mais
sa part entière essayons fabien roussel
m'a parlé et il a pas beaucoup de temps
de parole c'est bien aussi quelles
conditions les chars allaoui qui voit là
mais je vais je veux pas faire un débat
qui va commencer à s'enflammer et dans
trois secondes c'est à dire par là et on
peut dire c'est que comme d'habitude est
ce que vous avez lu reste voilà ce que
je lui répondrais quart monde et où tu
gouvernes sherco et avocate et pas
journaliste et animateur qui gouverne un
pays et c'est être tous les jours et
nous avons confronté à l'idée d'avoir
des incohérences ou de prendre des
mesures qui semblent incohérente aux
gens aux gros et d expliquer parce que
c'est ça la vie c'est comme ça qu'on
gouverne un état c'est pas simple ben
ouais vraiment fait plaisir à voir c'est
trop gros moi c'est moi je sais mais
qu'est ce que c'est trop gros lot ont
fait voter les gens n'avaient dit on les
avait évoqué aussi un petit libérés ils
vont nous ils vont libérer les gens au
moment des élections c'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est trop gros on avait dit il
vaccineront jamais les églises qui sont
gros tout est trop mieux fait de voter
aux élections quand je dis on je dire
avec soignants vous ne pourrez pas aller
travailler oui parce que vous avez cathy
focaux vide par contre vous pourrez
aller voter des gens positifs pourraient
donc désormais dans des veaux de des
bureaux de vote c'est trop gros ils ont
quoi père lui ils ont trop à perdre si
tu prends tous les cas contacts ça va
monter à 300 400 milles en isolement ils
vont se priver de 300 400 mille
personnes donc la i10 le port du masque
pourrait être conseillés par contre la
mascarade en attendant merci ce soir
comme vous
perdu le retard c'est tout l'argent
qu'on compte 7 du code et mon écoute
surtout ville n'a pas existé alors ses
décibels contre 6 alors que ce soit
annoncée par les gens nous arrêtent et
minsk on a décidé que les gens qu'on ne
peuvent pas voter ont été couverts
imaginons qu'il eut le droit de le faire
au bled c'est monsieur
laissez le vous diriez quoi
faut pas prendre cette maladie à la
rigolade on me faisait le même jour là
dans les travers
dénoncés noir vous dénoncez balade en
train d'attendre avant de dire le
combiné n'existe plus maintenant c'est
la guerre en ukraine et c'est le vote
qui est l'actuel c'est tout lorsque tu
en train de le dire à rossel je pense
que justement face à une pandémie c'est
pas tout blanc ou tout noir c'est
compliqué il ya eu beaucoup
d'incohérences dans la gestion qui s'est
déroulé je lis beaucoup d'incohérences
le monde y compris 100 mégabits du
confinement est relié par des millions
de gens iront dès il devait quand même
allé prendre le métro et et entassés les
uns contre les autres on n'avait pas le
droit d'aller au bistrot mais on avait
le droit de s'entasser dans le métro ça
mais ça on le sait un peu mais bien je
vais vous dire qu'un croyant mais je
l'avais trouvé ça très tôt j'ai dit
alors c'est une des différences que
j'aime et j'assume cette différence moi
j'ai défendu la vaccination je les
défends du d'ailleurs pour les pays
d'afrique parce qu' aujourd'hui en a que
10 % de vacciner quand il ya des
variantes qui apparaissent bien souvent
les apparaissent là parce que des
populations ne sont pas vaccinés donc je
me suis pas battu pour que les peuples
d'afrique et accès aux vaccins et pas le
peuple français je me suis battu avec
des maires pour qu'on puisse installer
des centres de vaccination pied des
tours au plus proche du monde du travail
des classes populaires et donc ça ça a
été mon combat je fais confiance à la
science je l'assument et dont le
bénéfice risques et
les dangers j'ai fait le choix moi
d'assumer le bénéfice du hac simple que
l'écho aujourd'hui aujourd'hui collectif
le bédéiste aux journaux aux objectifs
aujourd'hui on est le bénin aujourd'hui
en collectif ou de 150 morts par jour à
paraître aujourd'hui il ya encore 150
morts par jour par sept par cette
saloperie de virus
il est encore là bah oui et donc on doit
continuer de le combattre mais pour mais
qu'on a second à lever le matin et erre
d'aller voter cdu c'est pas aux
élections et je sais pas quoi mais au
premier tour on la noue souvient on en a
parlé avec edouard philippe c'était très
difficile à prendre des décisions très
très très difficile de prendre la
décision qu'est ce qu'on fait on confine
la démocratie alors là imaginer ce
qu'ils veulent plus de magro on va leur
dire c'est pas rêver même si les virus
est pas une il arrive maintenant bien
fleurie et laurent ils sont résolus si
on avait dit on va pas voter on aurait
dit oui
mais on joue complet est mort à
l'hôpital c'est maintenant tu peux je
parle
année environ 5,1 faut convaincre les
gens faut que il il dit trouve du
bénéfice du positif d'arguin c'est votre
cas on va se parler franchement c'est
votre gamelle ils sont en train de
sauver leur gamelle même si vous avez le
coc vide allez voter quand même parce
que c'est nos d'exactions à les y aller
sauver notre
[Musique]
je vois bien sûr ça mais imaginaire mais
non avec on disait repas des défunts
d'élections
dont on dit pat ya plus d'action on dit
si tu es positif aux copines tu ne vas
pas assez certain miné par une vieille
personne qui est donc tarson qui
positive à la malheureuse avez-vous des
voix dans un pays pourtant
s'il vous plaît on se calme il ya
quelqu'un qui dit en gros pendant les
élections le comité derrière et après
les émirats la revoilà donc si
le logiciel élevés doivent être levés
pour travaux officiels qu'on nous prend
pour des cons depuis deux ans on nous
explique que le coc vite c'est
extrêmement grave est que quand on là il
faut se confiner quoi qu'il arrive quoi
qu'il arrive sauf quand il faut aller
voter et à servir les intérêts des gens
qui nous ont confiné à liam est
abandonnée ont pas d attirer les gens
qui vont courir ici monsieur rousset
monsieur rugby et à vrai dire qu'il est
contre le 20 jours est là confiné mais
vous dit combien de cellules d'un léger
qu'on vous dit que le virus circule
toujours circulent toujours y circulent
partout on circule pas moins dans les
bureaux de bonnes que dans les
entreprises dont les restants donc ça
donne je suis désolée la sensation tinou
parra conserve le gouvernement qui l'a
élevé le pass sony dadc riant pour pas
récupéré leur boulot oui je croyais mais
ces parents là aujourd'hui on est soral
est réglé on est aux jeux camions sortis
d'une stagnation on a levé le pas de
sanitaires m eh bien on devrait aussi
permettre à ceux qui soignent de pouvoir
aller soigner sans megan a compris en
étant protégé d'ailleurs je vais vous
dire il y en a qu il ya des soignants
ils sont vaccinés ils ont fait tout ce
qu'il faut et il souffre aujourd'hui
d'un tri souffre parce qu'ils sont
surtout seul passer ça personnel soit
ils ont la charge deux ans et demi de
pandémie donc on a besoin de les
soutenir tous nos soignants et sans
exception il ya un doit être à côté de
fabrice et passe à côté du des fouilles
à laurent fontaine 15 couples pour y
répéter l'histoire des soignants ça va
être léger
gp2 et j'ai dit que je pense que les
situations de ce type vont être gérés
avec les syndicats avec les pouvoirs
publics ah oui pas c'est normal c'est
comme ça que ça tâter du dialogue a dit
d'ailleurs ça serait bien que les ja ja
du nez un peu fabrice donc c'est bien de
fond mabri bien comprendre le fond du
problème je suis 100% d'accord avec
laurent fontaine sur un point je veux
dire c'est à dire qu'en fait germer la
droite pas être d'accord on a le droit
d'être papa comme toi mais il ya un truc
qu'il faut jamais confiné si on serait
dangereux c'est la démocratie et que là
où je partage pas l'avis guillaume c'est
surtout de pardon de raymond sur la
question de la gamelle je n'aime pas ce
mot parce qu'en fait ça c'est réducteur
en fait que le vrai enjeu aujourd'hui il
ya et je signale au passage qu emmanuel
macron prend un risque en faisant ça
faut être honnête il prend un risque
parce que on sait qu'il a un électorat
qui est plutôt personnes âgées qui vont
être utilisés que d'avoir peur de se
déplacer c'est vrai qu'à la ville
invitant à résister majeur aussi pour ça
que c'est vrai pas pour eux nombreux
nourrir la gamelle de l'aso qui ont que
je veux dire c'est que je veux dire
c'est que derrière il ya un enjeu majeur
qui est de lutter contre l'abstention
donc ça c'est un enjeu majeur parce que
ça nous a tous le monde assertion
deuxième élément cependant il faut quand
même noter aujourd'hui que certaines des
personnes sont seuls dans les hôpitaux
sont seuls dans les hôpitaux et que même
lorsque tu es négatif taht essour mieux
pas sa liberté négatif tu ne peux pas
aller voir quelqu'un parce qu'il ya des
cas positifs dans l'hôpital dans le
service et que donc s'il ya cette
incohérence à laquelle est bien omnifone
pendant 15 jours à l'abri ce jeu vous
poser une question vous avez des enfants
oui votre enfant à un accident
extrêmement grave vous arrivez à
l'hôpital à qui vous donnez un gosse qui
l'a peut-être mourir à un mec à une
blouse blanche très belle un médecin
pourquoi vous ne fait pas plus confiance
aux médecins moi j'ai une crise
cardiaque demain je vais pas dire au
revoir avant de redonner du produit des
doigts exactement ce qui est dedans vous
êtes sûr que vous mais bon
on essaie des hôpitaux sont organisées
comme ça c'est qu'il ya peut-être une
raison ces cadets mais c'est la bonne
décision et plus de compétences que toi
et moi en
maladie et bien si jamais on va bien
roussel - excusez-moi mais je vous
respecte énormément je suis étonné de
votre manque total de combativité sur le
sujet faire que vous entériner une
décision électoraliste du gouvernement
vous savez très bien on tire un trait
sur le co vite vous êtes battus et là
vous dites oui au vrac elle doit je suis
d'accord mais là c'est une décision
électoraliste
on autorise tout le monde arrive aux
décisions ou il ya un canon lance deux
ans pas le droit et m'interdire l'accès
à bessat ses vols chez rossel et bientôt
on va faire de la loi par l'ong la
morale
tout le monde doit voter en masse toute
l'année et vous candidat à la présidence
de la république vous dites on se fout
du coc vide allons tous voter on ne
renie la banque elle que maintenant mais
je n'arrive en paraissent jose à
hiberner d'un homme avec autant
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui déçus par vaux
aujourd'hui on atteint l'immunité
collective et que j'espère vous en avez
à dire à vivre avec la pandémie malgré
cette saloperie de virus qui est
tellement calme et de milliers de cas
pamelo monsieur roussel on ne peut pas
interdire l'accès un bureau de vote pour
une raison pour une maladie mais mon
pauvre et moir correspondante en
amélioration
contaminés
anticonstitutionnel
replay on va se contaminer les actions à
venir que vous vous défendez l'idée que
l'on devrait intégrer les bureaux de
vote oui aux personnes positives du
covin la procuration ou par
correspondance
et ce qu'il a dit ça m'a formé et ce
sont ceux-là on est clair qu'il qu'il
fasse la procuration à lui simplifier et
donc on peut certes pardon non c'est pas
grave c'est pas pour vous c'est pas pour
votre site et projet doux et pour
fabriquer
qu'est-ce que vous avez là dessus oui ça
vous intéresse ça bien sûr ah bon
donneuse de leçons ça donne de leçons
bagis d'accord avec fabien roussel et
ben voilà le donneur de leçons qu
environ 7
voilà merci je voudrais dire aux filles
il ya un risque parce que dis-je il ya
un risque c'est que qu'est ce qui risque
de se passer c'est que ce sont les
positif à y voter quand même c'est à
dire que m'en donner si vous êtes
positifs mais que vous le dit pas bah
vous allez voter quand même c'est à dire
que abandonné de toute façon c'est pas
soluble comme quoi ya pas de solution
dans l'histoire et qu' abandonner dire
attendez c'est presque un mode rassure
mangeant veut dire du gouvernement de
dire attendez donc posé que vous êtes
même si vous êtes positif vous pouvez
aller voter l'apathie vous devez parce
que c'est un droit c'est pas une
obligation mais derrière c'est un petit
peu l'idée c'est de dire
sachez que même positif vous pouvez y
aller de toute façon il aurait fait
quand même ceux qui voulaient le faire
et ceux qui ne veulent pas y aller
n'iront pas de toute façon quelque part
dr pepper mort de l'apo un ace qui est
ancré en sim ce qui est incompréhensible
pour les français et qu'on a vécu
pendant le confinement c'est qu'on leur
a dit vous n'avez pas loin d'un lobby
secours avait passé sa loi et ça vous
n'avez pas le droit de l'autre mais vous
devez aller voter l'arrêt combatif
je comprends tellement contrat et donc
permettons permettons créons les
conditions pour les oraux restons et
nous en accusons sortir et faisons vivre
la démocratie aussi n'opposons pas les
choses c'est parce qu'on a un exercice
dont le sauver la gamelle mais
alors le regard n'a jamais évoqué cela
dit monsieur division tout à l'heure il
a dit j'aime pas ce que dirait mon
j'aime pas quand il parle bien mais ça y
est on a peur de l'abstentionniste ben
si tu as peur de la science une liste ma
cert a peur de ta gamelle